[Music]
in 19 bc
the roman poet virgil was traveling from
greece to rome with the emperor augustus
on the way he stopped to go sightseeing
in megura
a town in greece out in the sun for too
long
he suffered heat stroke and died on his
journey back to italy
on his deathbed virgil thought about the
manuscript he had been working on for
over 10 years
an epic poem that he called the aeneid
unsatisfied with the final edit he asked
his friends to burn it
but they refused and soon after virgil's
death
augustus ordered it to be published
why was augustus so interested in saving
virgil's poem
the romans had little tradition of
writing serious literature
and virgil wanted to create a poem to
rival the iliad and odyssey
of ancient greece the aniyad
a 9896 line poem
spans 12 separate sections or books the
first six of which
mirror the structure of the odyssey and
the last six
echo the iliad also like the greek epics
the aeneid is written entirely in
dactylic hexameter
in this meter each line has six syllable
groups
called feet made up of dactyls which go
long short short and spondees
which go long long so the famous
opening line in the original latin
starts
arma verum que cano which can be
translated as
i sing of arms and the man
arms meaning battles and warfare another
iliad reference
and the man being the hero aeneas
to understand the aeneid it's necessary
to examine the unsettled nature of roman
politics
in the second half of the first century
bc
in 49 bc julius caesar
augustus great uncle triggered nearly 20
years of civil war
when he led his army against the roman
republic
after introducing a dictatorship he was
assassinated
only after augustus's victory over mark
anthony and cleopatra
in 31 bc did peace return to rome
and augustus became the emperor
virgil aimed to capture this sense of a
new era
and of the great sacrifices that the
romans had endured
he wanted to give the romans a fresh
sense of their origins
their past and their potential by
connecting the founding of rome to the
mythological stories that his audience
knew so well
virgil was able to link his hero aeneas
to the character
of augustus in the epic poem
aeneas is on a quest to establish a new
home for his people
this duty or pietas as the romans called
it
faces all kinds of obstacles
aeneas risks destruction in the ruins of
troy
agonizes over love when he meets the
beautiful queen of carthage
dido and in one of the most vivid
passages in
all of ancient literature has to pass
through the underworld
on top of all that he must then fight to
win a homeland for his people
around the future site of rome
virgil presents aeneas as a sort of
model for augustus
and that's probably one of the reasons
the emperor was so eager
to save the poem from destruction but
virgil didn't stop there
in some sections aeneas even has visions
of rome's future
and of augustus himself virgil presents
augustus as a victor
entering rome in triumph and shows him
expanding the roman empire
perhaps most importantly he's hailed as
only the third roman leader
in 700 years to shut the doors of the
temple of janus
signifying the arrival of permanent
peace
but there's a twist virgil only read
augustus
three selected extracts of the story and
that
was augustus's entire exposure to it
some of the other sections could be seen
as critical if not subtly subversive
about the emperor's achievements
aeneas again a model for augustus
struggles with his duty and often seems
a reluctant hero
he doesn't always live up to the
behavior expected of a good roman leader
he struggles to balance mercy and
justice
by the end the reader is left wondering
about the future of rome
and the new government of augustus
perhaps in wanting the story published
augustus had been fooled by his own
desire for self-promotion
as a result virgil's story has survived
to ask
questions about the nature of power and
authority
ever since did you enjoy this lesson
if so please consider supporting our
non-profit mission
by visiting patreon dot com
slash ted ed